good afternoon colleagues --
rules committee for Monday April
first is hereby called order --
please advise the audio video
recording of today's proceedings
be maintenance also televised
I'm sorry for please call
the roll Cooley Cunningham
yeah flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove here Maienschein
Mathis quirk Silva here
from us here re best Wicks
we have a corpsman we have
consent agenda is our motion
like a senator it was kind
of secular by ms works --
etcetera please call the roll
Cooley hi Cooley aye Cunningham
Cunningham I Carillo hi Carillo
aye flora flora aye Grayson
Reyes and I can longer gov hi
Kamlager-Dove I Maienschein
Mathis Mathis I works over
my work so by Roman side from
most aye refills Wicks hi
motion soldiers pass and
this rules closer thank you
very much welcome to H.